je suis inquiet moi je dirais les gens
vont manifester aujourd'hui comme sais
pas si tu vas rentrer avec tes deux yeux
dire et on t'explique oecd violence
légitime la réciprocité etc
non moi je suis désolé je vois la sicile
mon discours ce n'est pas celui d'un
policier blanc le dit rapid à la 6e
place
quelle journée là on soutient d'ailleurs
si son soutien parce que l'organisation
syndicale des gens ce 6ème et la 10ème
train de se fissurer
il ya un directeur de cabinet du préfet
qui a parlé dans les médias
moi je reçois énormément de messages
anonymes parce que ça malheureusement
vous savez on va les trois leçons très
actif souhaite associer au jaune et
déplacés j'ai plein de collègues qu'ils
pensent exactement citoyens et des
dizaines avec des messages du grognon
peux pas le dire c'est ce mois ci au
barrage contre n'en sais rien a dit
comment ça dit tout ça dit aujourd'hui
la dépendance du pouvoir à l'égard de la
police et cette situation qui n'est pas
saine
évidemment la police doit pas être une
police du pouvoir mais ça devait être
une police des citoyens et donc à partir
de ce moment là et bien il faut
réinterroger qu'est-ce que comment
faucheux l'encadrement comment
fonctionnent les formations il ya un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui parce
que il ya une confiance réciproque
qu'ils soient retrouvées dans la société
française entre la population et la
police mais moi je place la
responsabilité centrale du côté du bras
et non pas du côté du marteau le bras
c'est de pouvoir qui décide de taper
avec le marteau et un moment qui laisse
le marteau libre de taper mais la
responsabilité celle du pouvoir qui doit
dire ce qu'elle veut faire ou ne pas
faire de sa police
puisque vous espérez une reconnaissance
de responsabilité des donneurs d'ordres
certains moments je veux dire elle est
en train d'émerger sur le plan
démocratique sans cesse sans que ça soit
sur le plan judiciaire mais oui les le
silence j'aurais dit pour chaque
policier blessé pour chaque gendarme
blessé dans l'hémicycle je me suis levé
avec mais les parlementaires de la
france insoumise
mais en un an on a un an de silence sur
les bancs de la majorité
quand il s'agit des personnes 25
personnes qui ont été épargnés ou des
cinq personnes qui ont perdu leurs bras
ce sont des compatriotes ils
n'appartiennent pas à un autre quand ils
apprennent partent elles tiennent à la
même nation
est ce que je réclame c'est du niveau de
la décence la décence morale c'est que
pour cela aussi on se lève dans les
missiles et que payer de l'humanité
voilà le la demande de macron à propos
du congé deuil et 28 yens une preuve
d'humanité de décence
allez il ya aussi des gens qui ont perdu
leur leurs mains ou qui ont perdu leurs